all right artemis
part of myself where'd you grow up where
are you from originally
so um i grew up in the midwest
kirksville missouri
i was born in greece
oh really
yes cyprus greece but
i grew up in kirksville missouri in a
household of nine
middle seven kids
i grew up with four sisters and two
brothers
um how do you describe your childhood
um chaotic and
wild
painful and
interesting
confusing and
kind of fun sometimes
but
yeah mom and dad
i grew up with a mother and father
senior
um sort of
not your actual mom and dad not my
biological parents
you were
adopted
that's
that would be a
safe assumption i think
um
i i always
i thought that my parents growing up
i started learning more and more the
more i branched out and the more i
more educated the more i reached out for
education and
to
to learn more
that's part of the reason why i dropped
out of college so many times
i just kept kept learning more
at such a rapid pace i couldn't focus on
only
what the colleges and universities
wanted me to focus on
i was going through
all kinds of personal crisis at the same
time as
attempting to
measure up to
the requirements of the educational
systems
just to learn
on what i wanted to learn to
get a career like the rest of my
siblings
what did you want to do with your life
honestly
i wanted to be a musician
um i wanted to travel the world and see
places go places and do things
i didn't just want to
i
didn't want to get stuck
in my hometown
but i didn't really consider it my
hometown considering the fact that i
didn't have
didn't really have friends i would my
consistent friends were with me all the
time
everyone that i that i knew
i cared about just either a disappeared
or
ended up somewhere else
or
b ended up like
hating the community that i grew up in
um it's just everybody either a
disappeared or b
right yeah it was pretty chaotic this is
a small town
in kansas
from missouri
northeast missouri
yeah it was pretty chaotic
um a lot of people i'm not going to
exaggerate it but a lot of people coming
in and out
a lot of
people can make them all all over the
midwest and
even from other countries
and i saw a lot of people come in and
out
a lot of people
and some reason
i don't know i just i i grew up with
like
i have a disability
i have phonographic hearing
so like i hear high-pitched sounds and
low-pitched sounds but
with my disability my form of autism
i remember all kinds of sounds
i i remember all of it and i can
it gets linked i can link it to like
memories and
locations and stuff if i hear a sound
so you're artistic as well
yes
i'm autistic and i'm artistic
but um
excuse me
is there any abuse in your childhood
yes
um
i was raped at age
four or five
and truth is
i was raped a lot but i don't remember a
lot of it because
i don't know how people got away with it
but
i've had flashbacks multiple times to
being in places like topeka kansas
i was tossed around a lot i don't know
how i ended up in all these situations
i just i've had dreams where like
flashbacks where i remember these things
then
um
just i grew up like i had sinned i was
raped i i have mainly female body parts
which is really weird to talk about i
learned
but um
you have both
yeah i have
i don't even know the names of all the
body parts but i have uterus and ovaries
you know
i don't want to so it makes you her mad
for diet
um i think so
people people joke like
sir ma'am guy or girl you know
and i don't really don't know how to
take it
because
i was
i think
i think i'd be more accepted in a more
liberal environment
or just remove one side or the other and
then i can
be accepted by people who want to call
me either a guy or girl
what do you identify as
honestly
i i would identify as a woman because i
want to i want to have kids one day
i was i was born with
a blonde spot my hair right here
and like i was
i looked a lot different
and i i remember having
i was forced like to take all kinds of
pills and stuff and
they put me on all kinds of
chemicals hormones
and stuff and they're changing me up
to try to make you more male or more
female they were making me more male
and
i remember just like even being at
school at the private school
just feeling so sick like i just didn't
want to be there
the environment was making me sick
even if i wasn't literally like
physically sick
i would i would just want to go home
sick
just just get out of the environment it
was really bad
i it was just so much
so much stress and
judgment and
the perspectives of the way the
it was kind of like the movie this is
how i see it the movie the village
um
are you aware of
it
um
it's about a cult in the woods
basically there's like some
some elders or whatever it's like kind
of like a religious community
but at night they keep the people there
by some of the elders dressed up as like
monsters
and they would scare people and keep
them there
but at the end of the movie this this
girl is blind comes to a chainmail fence
you have to keep in mind that the movie
is like it looks like it's in the 18 or
1700s
but this girl at the end of the movie
hits this chain well fence and the state
trooper pulls up
and you realize it was all all of this
this entire movie was inside of a state
park
and i was like wow that's basically how
i feel about
about me and how i how i got out here to
the state of california
i was in the middle of this
the situation it was just keeping me in
the dark
keeping me keeping me in a situation
where
i'll be continually consistently set up
to fail
and never
never
have
a chance to succeed or achieve my dreams
and
i feel like
last last july or
last july i feel like i just hit that
fence
and i realized i realized some things
i thought it's there now or never
i used to work
on
i used to have a job out here in the
state of california
so i just
i took a run for it
because
the man that raised me was using
i don't know how he does say he wanted
it's really hard to explain
in a in a short video but
he's moving the police around he's
moving he does all kinds of things
just with comfort of his home on the
computer
so i was lucky to make it to california
you've been in california how long since
last july
since july
5th or 6th
um i i'm just glad i made it out here
i've been alone all this this entire
time just by myself running
running and running
but you've been homeless in santa monica
since then
um well basically i've i have been
running around for like basically santa
monica all the way to long beach
just back and forth
where do you sleep at night
um
i just
wherever i can that wherever it's safe
um last night for example where you
stopped where i slept over by the pier
um
so i've learned a lot about energy
electromagnetic energy i've learned a
lot about
power supplies
communications all kinds of things like
that things i studied in college
um sociology communications
but these other things like
basically uh
i just
i've applied everything i know to
survival skills just to stay alive out
here
i i've been raped a lot in my past and
truth is i don't know how many times
it's a huge number and
i know i need medical attention i just i
don't want to get stuck in the hospital
system
or drugs a part of your life
they weren't originally until
i mean i smoked marijuana it was just
medical 100 medical for me
um cigarettes but
then last um
august september
um
i used crystal methamphetamine for the
first time
and if i
honestly i wish i didn't do it or i wish
i
wish something was different because
i don't want to have to use it ever
again but for some reason this um this
this stuff
if if i i don't know i started
withdrawing from it pretty quick
that's why you see these these spots on
my skin
um like on my shoulder and stuff on your
back yeah the spots on my back
um it just
works yeah i'm withdrawing from it
i don't want to have to go back but i
also don't want to have to
i i don't want to like
it's hard to explain but i don't want to
be an addict to
those drugs either
but um
yeah
how do you support yourself how do you
make money
i i really don't
make money
um i just do my best to get by i don't
have my id or wallet my passport
that stuff got stolen last year
i don't remember how it got stolen and
just
i didn't have time to panic and i just i
keep moving
i had to stay
stay stay alive stay
stay focused on staying alive i didn't
have time to
focus on my bigger dream to go to home
to my home country
i'd like to go to greece
i i wish i could i hope i can go home
someday i just
i've been praying desperately
desperately to get get home somewhere or
decrease her to missouri
greece or even like if i had a permanent
option where where i could be accepted
like have i don't want to do it alone
that's what i'm trying to say
um like with my male and female body
parts
if i were to stay in the usa i would
want the hospital systems to take me
seriously
so i could
maybe one day have kids
but basically i'm
i don't enjoy i'm
i'm
i'm asexual if that makes sense i don't
want to have sex with people just
because they think i need something
do you have
female body parts to in order to
reproduce
that's what i want to find out because a
lot of people think that
if i need something
like if i need if i need anything at all
they think they're they think i was free
game to rape they
it's hard to explain like people think
rape on the streets i've been raped on
the streets
i've been
yeah
i've been raped a lot of times and
i'm not trying to make a huge like
a huge list of people but there's a lot
of people
even high profile people in this country
that have
raised me in the past
and i really don't want to
don't want to go down that road of
judging and pointing fingers for people
but at the same time
i feel like some people take take me
like as a joke because i don't want to
because i'm not interested in playing
the
the judging game for other people
i'm trying to get help i'm trying to go
home to my home country even if i were
to stay in this country
i wouldn't i don't want to just stay
here alone
and i want to like i said the hospital
systems to take me seriously
i don't know how to explain it but
i don't have
like i have millions of dollars just to
i don't have i kind of
i don't have that kind of money just
i don't know how much it costs to get
the kind of surgery
and get my my parts my my body back
together
i mean
let me ask you a simple question do you
have a menstrual cycle
um
it's hard to explain i i didn't have sex
set in high school i went to private
school
so
to be honest with you here i don't even
understand some of these things i
i guess like that like i told you about
the movie the village it was like a cult
thing
i wasn't educated on sexual things
even though i have more sexual organs or
more
more um
there's more to my body than i that i
even need growing up
i just wish i knew that those things
growing up because let me ask just this
again do you i mean do you have to deal
with
a bloody discharge every month
oh no
not like that i just
i think my um
my
my hormones and stuff i don't know how
to explain it but like
i'm to the point where
like i have parts of my body that are
just shifting
and when i lay down
sometimes people magnetize like with the
electromagnetic energy they magnetize
parts of the ground
even remotely i feel like even some of
my bone marrow has been magnetized
and it's it's pretty pretty scary to go
through um
your bone marrow when it's get when your
bone marrow might be magnetized
it can leak it can come out your skin
and some of these spots i don't know if
it's it's just like pus coming out or
some of it might be actual bone marrow
my little sister had leukemia when i was
talking with the sores on your back yeah
i think this might be from the crystal
matthews yeah
but like uh there's other parts where
i just feel like something inside my
bones
and my little sister had leukemia when i
was a kid
um she didn't have bone marrow
transplant
and
i'm just curious as to i hope to hope
that's not the case but
how old are you 28 28.
do you have any friends
i do i don't have any way of getting a
hold of them i have a couple cousins in
huntington beach areas out here
do you speak with your family at all
not not who i am not my
the original that i grew up with
yes memories of your childhood you have
any good memories um
yes uh going out to the lake
i'm
fishing catching frogs
throwing firecrackers
all kinds of
basically the best memories i had were
with with my friends
when i was a kid
uh basically just
any hanging off being with friends
i'm going out in nature traveling
have you ever been in love artemis
um
when i was
when i was in school went to pittsburg
state university
i fell in love with this girl named
phoebe
sheena like
long story short i i just wanted to
marry her but
didn't realize like
i didn't even know what i was
like i didn't know that
some people thought i was gay or
something i didn't even know why people
thought these things
i wasn't educated in those those types
of ways but
about
four months into our relationship
we
broke up
and
um i was really depressed at that point
i was sleeping about 16 hours a day
really depressed
and about
i couldn't handle it anymore i was
sleeping that long every single day and
then finally um
i called my cousin in huntington beach
he got me a a job
over at um on the island catalina
all i had to do was have a phone
interview
i had a 10 question phone interview with
the director of operations
and
like i i sold all my stuff i got rid of
everything
i was living in the studio apartment
i sold my car
sold all my stuff i just
it wasn't even a week later i was about
six days
i was out there with my last hundred
dollars
so you moved to the island of catalina
yes two harbors
i i just jumped from what kind of job
was it
i worked as a campground ranger
kind of like a shadowing i like took
trash out um
like delivering firewood
taking care of the grounds just
all kinds of it was a whole new
experience a whole new world to open my
eyes up and how long did you stay there
honestly it was three months job
and then on my way back i ended up in
a hospital in littleton colorado
because
i was in the airport
to the denver airport
which is interesting and interesting
but like it's come up
because
my birth certificate said i was born in
denver
but i wasn't born in denver i was born
in greece
which is another interesting thing i
don't want to
dive too much or dive too deep into the
conspiracies right now
without being on something to be
paranoid
or you know what i'm saying kind of
emotions do you deal with no you get
depressed or anxious or angry
um
yeah
like
sadness
normally as much of depression a little
bit of depression
but
more like
i deal with a lot of just
really like
disappointment i guess
a really deep disappointment sadness
like i
i'm always
always
thinking like if i just expect
and just believe
that
something will happen
just believe in god and then which god
do am i supposed to believe in this time
and like it doesn't matter where i go i
got to find out who's who's the who's
the main god of that land or this land
or this area you know what i'm saying
like um in a group of people but in
order to survive in that group i just
try to
try to adapt based on
based on what their who their god is
and i'm always at this point where
i'm i'm always the last one
last one in or out and i i don't know if
i'm i'm gonna make it so i just
um basically i'm just i always just
prepare to be disappointed
and that's just that's just how it is
and
i'm i'm not trying to make anyone trying
to make you feel sorry for me but
you guys are afraid
what do you worry about
well
um i am afraid of
basically just
being the only one
like the only one
like
i'm afraid of never
never finding my way home
we're never getting there
i don't want to have to get there alone
at the same time
it's like i know my family is out there
somewhere
i mean i know home for you is where
in your mind
my mind
and
honestly
with with someone like with with
but
with family but also with family
at home in greece
or something like i don't know degrees
since you were born
no not since i was born
you think you came here after being just
a couple weeks old
yeah it was it was less than a week
a week did you still see greece as your
home
i want to go home and and just start
over
because
i wasn't supposed to be here in the
middle of all this that the conflict in
the first place
so what conflict are you
referring to
um
i grew up in the middle like um these
i don't know any other way to put it but
i don't know other than like
some books call them nickelations
i just call them traffickers
trafficking
humans drugs
they take advantage of people
basically just selfish people
they don't really care who they hurt or
who gets involved
i never sold my soul to any cause
i never swore to stay silent on anything
so as far as i'm concerned you can ask
any question
and i could probably answer you on any
level just
some people would verify it and then
they'd wonder how i came up with that
answer or how i got to it
the fact is
i don't even want to participate in the
the conflicts or the wars or the debates
especially when at the end of the day
i'm probably going to get taken
advantage of again and
like i said
in my shoes if there's any even one
person that comes in
comes into like
the same shoes as me the only thing i
could say is just prepare to
be disappointed
i've been been out here just on my own
still
i just don't want to get taken advantage
of at the same time
um
it just happens anyway so i just do my
best to fend for myself but
at the same time i don't want to get in
a situation where i could defend myself
physically
so i avoid certain types of conflict
particularly with like
violence you know
i i don't like to have to get in
situations i i avoid violence
all the time but
sometimes i'm just i get trapped in the
middle of it and
it's my own fault for having too much
faith
and expecting
too much good to happen
i should have just really checked myself
to my surroundings and realized
that all these all these other things
were in the middle of
all these other things around me and i i
just couldn't i had no control over it
all right artemis thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you and i wish
you the best of luck out there thank you
thank you very much
you